more than 2 800 pounds of cocaine
disguised as potatoes
let's
some poor Turtles
dude that makes me wanna eat potatoes
hello potatoes
brah dude if potatoes is cocaine
I mean you can have somebody you know
you're gonna have your little cousin
overdose on a damn waffle fry
you know
somebody
um
you know somebody got fentanyl all
Groton and then you know and now you got
to be at a funeral
it just is somebody going to get their
order supersized and hit the strip club
bro
it's a dark time
you get pulled over by the cops you're
like oh only I only had two fries bro
I only had two fries bro [__] man
I don't know
it's just
man
Home Fry is going to be called a halfway
house fries that's gonna be it
that's good it could look man you have
too many of them Mitch is he gonna be
living with about 11 dudes you never met
bunk bedding it
and doing meetings three times a day
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you a one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one